Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面 Dr. Marianne Trent，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是 Marianne Trent 博士。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. You may or may not know that it is possible to be a clinical psychologist but not necessarily have the doctorate title. That might well be because you qualified prior to 1995, where actually in the UK, clinical psychology was a master's taught subject. And so the doctorate wasn't conferred at the end of that qualification. But of course, it might be because you did your training in a different country where the doctorate wasn't granted as part of that training. But what I know is that all of those people are still highly skilled and qualified, and absolutely do brilliant work. So today, we're going to be talking to somebody who is a clinical psychologist, but qualified in
你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。你可能知道，也可能不知道，一个人可以成为临床心理学家，但不一定拥有博士头衔。这很可能是因为你在 1995 年之前获得了资格，当时在英国，临床心理学是一门硕士教学科目，因此在该资格结束时并未授予博士学位。当然，也可能是因为你在其他国家完成了培训，而该培训并未授予博士学位。但我知道，所有这些人依然是技术精湛、资质合格的专业人士，并且绝对在从事着出色的工作。所以今天，我们将采访一位临床心理学家，但她是在
a different country, and then came to the UK and hearing about their journey we're also going to be thinking about perfectionism and whether it's a good thing whether it's a bad thing and what we can do about it to be more compassionate to ourselves hope you find it so useful and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side hi just want to welcome along my guest for today, Michaela Thomas. Hi, Michaela. Hi, Marianne. So good to have me as a guest. I'm really looking forward to it. Thank you. Lovely. Thank you. So you and I know each other. We first met on social media, I think, didn't we, in a qualified psychologist network. But yeah, we ended up doing that thing where you slip into each other's
另一个国家获得的资格，然后来到英国。在了解她的历程时，我们还将探讨完美主义，思考它究竟是好是坏，以及我们能做些什么来对自己更慈悲。希望你觉得这期节目很有用，期待在节目后与你交流。你好，欢迎我的嘉宾 Michaela Thomas。你好，Michaela。你好，Marianne。很高兴能作为嘉宾参加节目，我非常期待。谢谢。太好了，谢谢。你我相识已久，我想我们最初是在社交媒体上的一个合格心理学家网络中认识的，对吧？但后来我们确实做到了那种会溜进对方
inboxes and then never leave yeah you're the most most reliable reply to my mailing list comes from you so I know especially if I do something slightly more sort of thought-provoking or something in the in the text uh for the subject headline then I know Marianne's gonna take the bite and she's going to reply. I do. I love replying to people's mailing list emails. And that said, if anyone listening to this gets my mailing list email, it's okay to reply. We love it. We love it. I think people think, oh, it's just, it's just, you know, it's a one-sided communication, but it is an email. You are allowed to to reply so you are also a clinical psychologist aren't you Michaela indeed I am actual qualified psychologist love that love that if in case you're not sure what the reference to actual psychologist
收件箱里就再也不出来的事情。是的，你是我邮件列表中最可靠的回复者，所以我知道，如果我在邮件主题行里写了一些稍微发人深省的内容，Marianne 一定会“上钩”并回复我。确实如此。我喜欢回复人们的邮件列表。话虽如此，如果正在听节目的任何人收到了我的邮件，欢迎回复。我们很喜欢这样。我想人们可能觉得这只是单向沟通，但它确实是一封邮件，你是可以回复的。你也是一位临床心理学家，对吧，Michaela？确实，我是真正的合格心理学家。太棒了。如果你不确定“真正的心理学家”是指什么，
is I did an episode with another of our friends and colleagues, Tara, Dr. Tara Quincherillo. And she is a counselling psychologist. But we think about actual psychologists as professional psychologists with a qualification and registration, you know, being a qualified and I suppose in some ways scrutinized psychologists meaning that we adhere to the professional code of conduct and standards um of our profession and i think this is obviously a bugbear of both yours and mine and tara's of how there are charlatans out in the media talking about psychological concepts without being a qualified clinical counseling health whatever psychologist so that's why we are the actual psychologists because we do have those professional standards and boundaries.
我曾与我们的另一位朋友兼同事 Tara，即 Tara Quincherillo 博士做过一期节目。她是一位咨询心理学家。我们认为“真正的心理学家”是指拥有资格和注册的专业心理学家，你知道，是合格的，而且在某种程度上是受到监督的心理学家，这意味着我们遵守职业行为准则和行业标准。我认为这显然是你、我和 Tara 共同的痛点，即媒体上有一些江湖骗子在谈论心理学概念，却并非合格的临床、咨询、健康或其他领域的心理学家。这就是为什么我们是“真正的心理学家”，因为我们拥有那些专业标准和界限。
Yeah, I love that and I'm so proud to be a professionally qualified psychologist and I know you feel the same as well. Anyway, this is an aside. This is an aside. We're here today to think about a variety of things but because you are not originally from the UK but you do work and practice here now I thought it would be really lovely if you're able to share a little bit with our listeners and our watchers over on YouTube about how you came to be a clinical psychologist and how you came to practicing in the UK and and how the transition has been from one country to another? Sure it's not been an easy ride by any means. I was born in Sweden and I did my
是的，我很喜欢这一点，我也为自己是一名专业合格的心理学家感到自豪，我知道你也有同感。总之，这只是题外话。我们今天在这里是为了思考各种各样的事情，但因为你并非来自英国，但现在在这里工作和执业，我想如果你能与我们的听众和 YouTube 上的观众分享一下你是如何成为临床心理学家的，以及你是如何来到英国执业的，还有从一个国家到另一个国家的过渡是怎样的，那会非常棒。当然，这绝非易事。我出生在瑞典，我在那里完成了
my doctoral training there or sort of the equivalent of your doctoral training I should say this is something that we've talked about before so it triggers my imposter syndrome that I quote-unquote only get a master's for the equivalent training to what you have in the UK so we don't actually award a doctorate and I know historically that wasn't the case in the UK either it's more of a recent development isn't it so although I am a registered and qualified psychologist where I hold professional registration in both countries both Sweden and the UK I can't call myself a doctor so I'm not Dr Michaela Thomas because we then do a longer program where you have the undergrad and the postgrad rolled into one so that's the five-year psychology program whereas when you get into that
我的博士培训，或者说相当于你们的博士培训。我应该说，这是我们之前讨论过的事情，它触发了我的冒名顶替综合症，因为我“仅仅”获得了硕士学位，而这相当于你们在英国所拥有的培训，因为我们实际上并不授予博士学位。我知道在英国历史上情况也并非如此，这更多是近期的发展，对吧？所以，虽然我是一名注册且合格的心理学家，在瑞典和英国两国都拥有专业注册，但我不能称自己为博士，所以我不是 Michaela Thomas 博士。因为我们实行的是更长的课程，将本科和研究生阶段合二为一，也就是五年的心理学课程。而当你进入那个阶段时，
you are also expecting to come out the other side of that as a psychologist in training so you don't have to do the sixth final year um where it's basically a supervised post but you are no longer attached to university so you do 12 months not like a placement you are working you're salaried you are a you know one of the staff members but you just have to have um someone supervise you and that supervisor then has to sort of just sign off on your 12 months at the end of it to see that you're you know you're suitably um able to practice independently after that so it's a six-year process but that means that our bottleneck isn't you know in between the undergrad and the postgrad like it is here um is really really difficult to get into that first year and the the benefit of that I suppose is that once you're
你也期望在课程结束时成为一名实习心理学家，所以你不必完成第六个最后一年，那基本上是一个受监督的岗位，但你不再隶属于大学。所以你做 12 个月，不像实习，你是在工作，有薪水，你是员工之一，但你只需要有人监督你，而那位主管需要在最后签署你的 12 个月工作，以证明你在那之后能够独立执业。所以这是一个六年的过程，但这意味着我们的瓶颈不像这里那样在本科和研究生之间。进入第一年确实非常非常困难，而我认为这样做的好处是，一旦你
in you know you're gonna if you manage the five years you're gonna come out the other end as a psychologist in training and then qualified psychologist after the sixth year whereas the downside is that there's a there's a lot of psychology training to go through if you're not quite sure that that's what you want if you drop out after the first three years you can then account that to be a BSc in psychology so you can kind of take that part qualification away if you then feel like I don't want to do clinical training I want to use psychology as a base for other kind of training for instance I want to go into business management or whatever it might be so it's not a waste quote unquote if you feel like I'm
进去了，如果你能坚持完这五年，你就会在第六年结束时成为一名实习心理学家，然后成为合格的心理学家。而缺点是，如果你不确定这是否是你想要的，那么需要经历大量的心理学培训。如果你在前三年后退学，你可以将其算作心理学理学学士学位，所以如果你觉得我不想做临床培训，我想把心理学作为其他培训的基础，例如我想进入企业管理或其他领域，你还是可以带走部分资格。所以如果你觉得
you know part way through the process this is not for me when you get to the more applied psychology and your placements which are in the final two years or three years it's a blur this was a long time ago I was 19 when I first got in so that process was interesting as well because on my cohort I was the youngest. It was really rare to get in that early because I got into my, on my first attempt. I had people who were like 45 on the course. He was, this was their second career and that's quite common in Sweden
在过程中途这不适合我，那也不是浪费。当你进入更偏向应用心理学的阶段和实习期时，那是在最后两年或三年，这很模糊，那是很久以前的事了。我 19 岁时第一次进入这个领域，所以那个过程也很有趣，因为在我的同届学生中我是最年轻的。那么早进入真的很罕见，因为我是第一次尝试就成功了。课程里还有 45 岁左右的人，这是他们的第二个职业，这在瑞典很常见，
because it's not starting with sort of with an undergrad as such. So yeah, it was a really interesting way of learning and there was lots of practical learning on the job we had an in-house clinic at the university department we then had people from the general public who could come and see the psychologists in training and it was run like as if you're having your own clinic so that was really helpful because it had to manage not just the clinical issues but also managing your time you know as if you were in a workplace with other psychologists you know the
因为它不是从本科开始的。所以，这是一种非常有趣的教学方式，工作中有很多实践学习。我们在大学系里有一个内部诊所，普通大众可以来找实习心理学家看病，它的运作方式就像你拥有自己的诊所一样。这非常有帮助，因为它不仅要处理临床问题，还要管理你的时间，就像你在与其他心理学家一起工作的职场中一样，你知道，
classic room fights who's overrunning their slot and taking someone else's room space classic love it very public sector and I found it really helpful as a way to get a real feel for the profession so when I qualified I worked for about six months in a camp service in Sweden specializing in adolescence with depression anxiety so for a while I've been looking at IAPT in the UK I sort of had this dreamy aspiration that IAPT was going to be everything that I've ever wanted um so I moved to the UK I got into the IAPT program um and then I did seven years in two different London IAPT services uh before I sort of took the plunge to fully work with my private practice that I now run solely online so the Thomas Connection is my
经典的房间争夺战，谁超时了，占用了别人的房间空间，经典，我喜欢。非常公共部门的风格。我发现这对于真正了解这个职业非常有帮助。所以我获得资格后，在瑞典的 CAMHS（儿童与青少年心理健康服务）工作了大约六个月，专门研究患有抑郁症和焦虑症的青少年。所以有一段时间我一直在关注英国的 IAPT（改善心理治疗服务），我有一种梦想，觉得 IAPT 会是我想要的一切。所以我搬到了英国，进入了 IAPT 项目，然后在伦敦的两个不同的 IAPT 服务机构工作了七年，之后我才下定决心全身心投入到我现在完全在线运营的私人诊所中。The Thomas Connection 就是我的
practice um so that's sort of a little bit around how I've got here but there's a bit of a chunk there missing which is how on earth did I get from Sweden to the UK how did I get my qualifications acknowledged and that did take a couple of years for HCPC or HPC as it was called at the time uh to acknowledge that my training was equivalent. So did you have to do that before you got to the UK you couldn't sort of stump like show up and then be like oh I quite fancy working as a qualified psychologist? Well this is this is exactly why I found it so helpful to come in through the IAP program because at that point I was then given the permission to be a trainee again
诊所。所以这就是我如何走到这一步的一点背景，但中间缺失了一大块，那就是我到底是怎么从瑞典来到英国的？我是如何让我的资格得到认可的？HCPC（健康与护理专业委员会，当时叫 HPC）确实花了几年的时间才承认我的培训是等同的。所以你必须在来到英国之前就完成这些吗？你不能直接过来，然后说“哦，我想作为一名合格的心理学家工作”？嗯，这正是为什么我发现通过 IAPT 项目进入非常有帮助的原因，因为在那时，我被允许再次成为一名实习生。
I was a CBT therapist in training obviously they've hired me recruited me knowing I was then given the permission to be a trainee again. I was a CBT therapist in training. Obviously, they've hired me, recruited me, knowing I was a qualified psychologist, but I couldn't work with that title. I was a trainee CBT therapist. So yes and no. So yeah, I had to do a lot of things before I left. The HCPC have a lot of hoops that you have to work and jump through in terms of showing that the training you've gone through is the equivalent so I had to single-handedly translate about 80 pages of Swedish course curriculum information so you know what every single five-week course even I'd taken included and what the learning objectives were etc and then get that approved from the university again so sending it back to them to say does this
我当时是一名在训的 CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗师。显然，他们雇佣我、招募我时知道我是一名合格的心理学家，但我不能使用那个头衔。我是一名在训的 CBT 治疗师。所以，既是也不是。是的，我在离开前必须做很多事情。HCPC 有很多门槛，你必须在证明你所经历的培训是等同的方面去努力和跨越。所以我不得不单枪匹马地翻译了大约 80 页的瑞典课程大纲信息，这样他们就知道我修过的每一门五周课程都包含了什么，学习目标是什么等等，然后再次获得大学的批准，把这些发回给他们，问这
translation match your your objectives and so I basically sent about two kilos of paperwork to HCPC and that also included a well-being check that you had to go and see a private doctor to who assessed you whether you were suitable or whatever I was suitable to practice independently you know as a psychologist and the doctor just looked at me like well I could check your hearing and your your sight and your reflexes but I have no idea how to assess that you can actually practice so shall I do that and she took 80 quid um so the bizarre things were also I had to get someone to attest to me being of a good standing in society or something to that extent I can't remember this is a long time ago and I was like 15 years ago
翻译是否符合你们的目标。所以我基本上给 HCPC 发了大约两公斤的文件，其中还包括一份健康检查，你必须去看私人医生，评估你是否适合，或者我是否适合独立执业，你知道，作为一名心理学家。医生看着我，就像是“好吧，我可以检查你的听力和视力以及反射，但我不知道如何评估你是否真的能执业，那我该做吗？”她收了 80 英镑。所以奇怪的事情还有，我必须找人证明我在社会上声誉良好，或者类似的事情，我不记得了，这是很久以前的事了，大约 15 年前，
like a moral moral standing yeah something like that and you had to have someone who'd known you for at least 10 years or something like a big chunk and I had to attest to you being of you know a sound mind as opposed to be able to practice in this delicate profession so I had to attest to you being of you know a sound mind as opposed to be able to practice in this delicate profession so I had to find you know what my oldest friend is a lawyer so she had to write and she's making lots of rude jokes as she was writing it but attest to that I was sound to practice so all of these things put together in a portfolio similar to how perhaps people put together a portfolio within IAPT within that training as well to to showcase your knowledge skills and aptitudes attitudes KSA yeah knowledge
像道德立场之类的，是的，类似那样。你必须找一个认识你至少 10 年的人，或者类似的一大段时间，证明你是一个心智健全的人，而不是能够在这个微妙的职业中执业。所以我必须找，你知道，我最老的朋友是一名律师，所以她不得不写信，她在写的时候开了许多粗鲁的玩笑，但证明了我适合执业。所以所有这些东西放在一个文件夹里，类似于人们在 IAPT 培训中整理的文件夹，以展示你的知识、技能和态度（KSA），是的，知识、
skills and attitudes so I had to do one of those as well um so there was a lot of paperwork and I think without the tenacity of I'm doing this I've've been given the post, I'm going to go for it, it wouldn't have worked out, I think. So for anyone who's listening who comes from a foreign country, again, it's very difficult to say what it would be like for you. This is, you know, well over a decade ago that I came to the UK. It was about 12 years ago. But it's helpful to have a dialogue with the HPC as well about what are they looking for. So when I first applied to get my practitioner psychologist,
技能和态度。所以我也不得不整理一份这样的文件。所以有很多文书工作，我想如果没有那种“我正在做这件事，我已经得到了这个职位，我要去争取”的韧性，我想它是不会成功的。所以对于任何正在听节目的来自外国的人，同样，很难说这对你来说会是什么样。这是我来到英国十多年前的事了，大约 12 年前。但与 HPC 进行对话，了解他们正在寻找什么也很有帮助。所以当我第一次申请成为执业心理学家时，
they passed it back and said, you're missing something, was pretty much. I was like, well, what am I missing? Can you be a bit more clearer? So then I went push. They sort of said, well, we need you to have more practical experience of older adults so none of my placements had been with older adults in Sweden they've all been with adolescent children adolescent and adults so then I was given a couple of clients within IAPT in my
他们把它退了回来，说你缺少一些东西，基本上就是这样。我说，好吧，我缺少什么？你能说得更清楚一点吗？所以我继续追问。他们说，我们需要你有更多关于老年人的实践经验，因为我在瑞典的实习中没有一个是关于老年人的，它们都是关于青少年、儿童和成人的。所以后来我在 IAPT 的服务中被分配了几个客户，
service that I was with documented all that sent it back in and that was enough so just yeah don't take no for an answer ask for why um what's missing how do i add to this what's what's the kind of what complementing information are you looking for and then don't give up have lots of tenacity seek support from friends allow it to take a long time i think it probably took me two years of actually being in the uk before i got my qualification at that point i would already qualified as a cbt therapist for the second time because I was already qualified CBT therapist from Sweden but you know you'd have to know that you want to be here for that to feel worthwhile absolutely it sounds like the HCPC kind of will tell you if you push the right buttons but of course when we first started
记录了所有这些，发回去了，这就足够了。所以，是的，不要接受“不”作为答案，询问原因，缺少什么，我该如何补充，你们在寻找什么样的补充信息？然后不要放弃，要有韧性，寻求朋友的支持，允许它花很长时间。我想我来到英国后可能花了两年时间才获得资格。那时我已经第二次获得了 CBT 治疗师的资格，因为我已经是从瑞典获得的合格 CBT 治疗师，但你知道，你必须确定你想留在这里，这样才觉得值得。绝对的。听起来 HCPC 如果你按对了按钮就会告诉你，但当然，当我们刚开始
training the BPS the british psychological society were our professional body and that's changed it certainly uh just before i qualified i think it changed to the hcpc have the bps or are the bps any use in guiding this process for people that live outside the uk to your knowledge um the honest answer is that when I came to move here in 2010 the overseas route for applying was closed they were just not accepting it so since then I've just never bothered I've never applied for the BPS because it's not seemed to serve my ongoing career and my you know the professional skills I have I might feel differently about it now or in the future but it's just never really felt like anything I needed because I already
培训时，BPS（英国心理学会）是我们的专业机构，现在已经变了。确实，在我获得资格前不久，我想它变成了 HCPC。据你所知，BPS 是否对指导居住在英国以外的人进行此过程有任何用处？诚实的回答是，当我 2010 年搬到这里时，海外申请渠道是关闭的，他们根本不接受。从那以后，我从未费心申请过 BPS，因为它似乎对我持续的职业生涯和我所拥有的专业技能没有帮助。我现在或将来可能会有不同的看法，但它从来没有让我觉得是我需要的，因为我已经
had to have HCPC and I had to have BABCP as my governing body for the CBT therapy so I sort of felt what does the BPS add if I'm really honest about it what does it add apart from you know another professional fee to pay so I just haven't because it wasn't a route that was available and open to me in 20. Well, I moved in 2010, but I've been looking at this for years before that. So from about 2007 and it just wasn't an access route for me. So I found a way in, which was through IAPT and then added the other bits as I went along. Great. Thank you and what what was the appeal of the UK for you other than you know having a crystal ball and knowing that you'd meet someone
有了 HCPC，而且我有 BABCP 作为我的 CBT 治疗机构。所以老实说，如果我真的说实话，BPS 除了增加另一笔专业费用外，还能增加什么？所以我没有申请，因为它在 20 年时不是一个对我开放的渠道。好吧，我是 2010 年搬来的，但我在此之前已经关注了好几年。所以从 2007 年左右开始，它对我来说就不是一个准入渠道。所以我找到了一个进入的方法，那就是通过 IAPT，然后随着我的进展添加其他部分。太棒了。谢谢，除了你知道拥有水晶球并知道你会遇到某人
and have a family and you know live your happily ever after why the UK why was that an appeal to you? Yeah well I'd always liked London I, who doesn't like a major metropolis? But it was also, I mean, I wanted to get a good career. I was obviously recently qualified and I'd seen some people like John Wheatley and Glenn Waller, people who were sort of CBT therapists who were also involved in IAPT. They'd come for workshops to Sweden and I'd been speaking to Glenn Waller about it and what the program looked like. And, you know, what's the difference between sort of going for the CBT therapy route versus the ClinPsych route. And I at the time really loved therapy.
并组建家庭，过上幸福的生活之外，英国对你有什么吸引力？为什么是英国？为什么它对你有吸引力？是的，我一直很喜欢伦敦，谁不喜欢大都市呢？但这也是，我的意思是，我想获得一份好的职业。我显然是刚获得资格，我见过一些人，比如 John Wheatley 和 Glenn Waller，他们是 CBT 治疗师，也参与了 IAPT。他们来瑞典参加研讨会，我一直在和 Glenn Waller 谈论它，以及这个项目是什么样子的。而且，你知道，走 CBT 治疗路线和临床心理学路线有什么区别。当时我真的很喜欢治疗。
And I felt that the way in via IAPT felt more like I was able to use the skills that I had and wanted. And I really loved the initiative of improving access to psychological therapy we are you know we have we were doing primary care psychology in Sweden as well as well and it was sort of starting to develop but I liked what David Clark had been doing with IAPT now having worked in it a slightly different story but that will be another podcast episode I'm sure but I just I just felt the passion for that and wanting to be part of that system and I had been having long distance with someone for three years who at that point was based in London so I felt that you know if I get the right job I can move to London and we can you know make
我觉得通过 IAPT 进入的方式让我觉得我能够使用我所拥有的和想要的技能。我真的很喜欢改善心理治疗服务（IAPT）的倡议，我们在瑞典也有初级保健心理学，它也开始发展，但我喜欢 David Clark 在 IAPT 所做的事情。现在在其中工作过，故事就有点不同了，但我相信那将是另一期播客节目。但我只是，我只是感受到了那种热情，想要成为那个系统的一部分。而且我和一个当时在伦敦的人进行了三年的异地恋，所以我感觉到，如果我能找到合适的工作，我就可以搬到伦敦，我们可以，你知道，让
a go of this relationship I didn't want to just move somewhere and not have something that was furthering my you know my purpose and what I trained for as well. So when that came up, I thought, well, everything is aligned. Now, my work in psychology has obviously lasted another 12 years, but that relationship did not. And I met who is now my husband not long after that in 2012. I met him in 2012. So, yeah, so that's lasted a decade and so has my psychology interest but not the relationship I moved to the UK for I don't think I realized
这段关系成功。我不想只是搬到某个地方，却没有做任何能促进我的目标和我所受培训的事情。所以当那个机会出现时，我想，一切都对齐了。现在，我在心理学方面的工作显然又持续了 12 年，但那段关系没有。我在那之后不久，2012 年遇到了我现在的老公。我是在 2012 年遇到他的。所以，是的，那持续了十年，我对心理学的兴趣也持续了十年，但我搬到英国是为了那段关系，我不认为我意识到了
I don't think I realized about the other relationship I love I love knowing that it sounds romantic though and you know you had that in mind and you had like that perseveration and commitment and drive. And that's so important in psychology. And even hearing you, as you're talking about all the hoops that you needed to jump through, transcribing and translating and all of that for your work, that takes a great deal of drive and determination and commitment as well and so is it any wonder that in the profession of psychology we've got quite a few perfectionistic traits you know because even people that have qualified in the UK you know the level of the academic rigor and the clinical rigor and what we've got to balance alongside our lives and all
我不认为我意识到了关于另一段关系的事。我喜欢，我喜欢知道这一点，虽然听起来很浪漫，而且你心里有那个想法，你有那种坚持、承诺和动力。这在心理学中非常重要。即使听你谈论你需要跨越的所有门槛，为你的工作进行转录、翻译等等，这也需要极大的动力、决心和承诺。所以难怪在心理学这个职业中，我们有相当多的完美主义特质，你知道，因为即使是那些在英国获得资格的人，你知道，学术严谨性和临床严谨性的水平，以及我们必须在生活中平衡的事情，以及
of that and demonstrating and talking about our competencies we do have quite a few perfectionistic candidates and personnel within um within psychology don't we Michaela absolutely I think I was once told on a schema therapy training that to the most common schemas that we see showing up for psychologists is self-sacrifice and perfectionism and there's a reason why i built my entire practice to be specialized in in perfectionism because i've struggled with this in the past myself and i would say that i'm a recovering perfectionist i don't let it ruin my life anymore I don't let it sort of zap joy out of my life I don't let it impact the connection I have with others anymore because I've found ways
所有这些，展示和谈论我们的能力，我们在心理学中确实有相当多的完美主义候选人和人员，不是吗，Michaela？绝对的。我想我曾经在一次图式治疗培训中被告知，心理学家最常见的两种图式是自我牺牲和完美主义。我之所以建立整个诊所专门研究完美主义，是有原因的，因为我自己过去也曾为此挣扎，我会说我是一个正在康复的完美主义者。我不再让它毁掉我的生活，我不再让它从我的生活中榨取快乐，我不再让它影响我与他人的联系，因为我已经找到了
of working with myself self you know with self-compassion and behavioral change so I think it's so rife in psychologists I mean I do coaching and therapy also for psychologists, especially, and people come my way quite a lot with these kind of very hard on themselves, very, you know, maybe low sense of confidence and self-belief. And this idea that almost like a sense of shame about wanting to have something for themselves as well as serving others especially as private business owners we can obviously see that you know I do need to charge I do need to make money off the work I do and when I work with other private psychology owners people who are in private practice they are entrepreneurs and they really struggle to kind of identify with this idea that I'm an entrepreneur I'm a business owner because we just want to serve. And that perfectionism of selflessly self-sacrificing might mean that they have real lack of boundaries. They might work, you know, three, four evening clinics or having 30 clients
与自己相处的方式，通过自我慈悲和行为改变。所以我认为这在心理学家中非常普遍。我的意思是，我也为心理学家提供辅导和治疗，人们经常带着这种对自己非常苛刻、非常，你知道，可能缺乏自信和自我信念的感觉来找我。这种想法，几乎就像一种羞耻感，关于想要为自己拥有一些东西，同时也服务他人，特别是作为私人企业主，我们显然可以看到，你知道，我确实需要收费，我确实需要从我的工作中赚钱。当我与其他私人心理学所有者、私人执业者一起工作时，他们是企业家，他们真的很难认同“我是一名企业家，我是一名企业主”这个想法，因为我们只是想服务。那种无私的自我牺牲的完美主义可能意味着他们真的缺乏界限。他们可能工作，你知道，三个、四个晚间诊所，或者一周有 30 个客户。
across the week. And we see this also in public health health where perfectionism is something that makes people take you know i'm looking for the right word here excessive notes and spending an hour to update the clinical notes for for a patient and they might over prepare for supervision so that they spend two hours preparing for supervision and then feeling like i don't have enough time so we see a lot of the similar behaviors that you might see in OCD because perfectionism can be a part driving part of OCD and some people with OCD you know fall prey to kind of this idea that if I don't do it something bad will happen and we can have that in perfectionism as well so it's really helpful to maybe identify that perfectionism is like an umbrella term that can host lots of things underneath it. So perfectionism as itself is not a clinical diagnosis from the DSM-5 or anything
我们在公共卫生领域也看到了这一点，完美主义让人们，你知道，我在找合适的词，做过多的笔记，花一个小时更新一个病人的临床笔记，他们可能会为督导过度准备，以至于花两个小时准备督导，然后觉得我没有足够的时间。所以我们看到了很多你在强迫症（OCD）中可能看到的类似行为，因为完美主义可以是强迫症的一个驱动部分，一些强迫症患者，你知道，沦为这种想法的牺牲品，即如果我不这样做，坏事就会发生，我们在完美主义中也会有这种情况。所以，也许可以识别出完美主义是一个伞形术语，可以在其下容纳很多东西，这非常有帮助。所以完美主义本身不是 DSM-5 或任何类似的东西中的临床诊断，
like that, but it's very commonly associated with anxiety and depression. And we as psychologists or aspiring psychologists in training are not immune to mental health problems like anxiety and depression so being aware of these patterns of perfectionism before they lead to stress burnout low self-esteem anxiety depression is really really important because there is no such thing as perfect and your training your career your application process none of it can be perfect it's almost ironic though isn't it because if you didn't know what perfectionism was sounds great like oh perfectionism oh and it sounds like you'd be really happy doesn't it yeah because the opposite is true
但它非常普遍地与焦虑和抑郁相关联。而我们作为心理学家或在训的心理学家，对焦虑和抑郁等心理健康问题并不免疫。所以，在这些完美主义模式导致压力、倦怠、低自尊、焦虑、抑郁之前意识到它们是非常非常重要的。因为世界上没有完美这回事，你的培训、你的职业、你的申请过程，没有一个是完美的。这几乎很讽刺，不是吗？因为如果你不知道什么是完美主义，听起来很棒，就像“哦，完美主义，哦”，听起来你会非常快乐，不是吗？是的，因为事实恰恰相反。
but the opposite is true and actually like you said they're quite often very highly stressed and quite miserable they're not they're not thriving, are they? They're, you know, tinkering, tinkering, is that a word? Fal're dancing on the deadline of of everything and it can be very difficult because that can lead to patterns of procrastination as well that when you are working so hard that you don't have a sustainable pace you're kind of going into boom or bust um you know actually i'm doing everything and then i'm so exhausted i can't be bothered to do anything or i might even feel low and flat so in the the up phase, when you're working on really hard or maybe completing your application or applying for jobs, you might not feel like, okay, I've got this sort of energy,
但事实恰恰相反，实际上就像你说的，他们通常压力非常大，非常痛苦。他们没有，他们没有茁壮成长，对吧？他们，你知道，修补，修补，这是一个词吗？在所有事情的截止日期上跳舞，这可能非常困难，因为这也可能导致拖延模式，当你工作得如此努力以至于没有可持续的节奏时，你就会进入繁荣或萧条，你知道，实际上我正在做所有事情，然后我精疲力竭，我无法打起精神做任何事情，或者我甚至可能感到低落和麻木。所以在上升阶段，当你工作非常努力，或者可能完成你的申请或申请工作时，你可能不会觉得，好吧，我有这种能量，
but it can be a really adrenaline and cortisol-fueled energy that makes you just kind of like burn all the cylinders. And then as a response to that, because your body eventually says no, you can then enter into a bit of a slump where you then kind of come into the bust and that's where we you know with repeated cycles like that can even find things like chronic pain you know your body has just literally depleted all its resources so you've run through all the cortisol that you have and that can make it really difficult to get motivated to take action and procrastination can be something that follows that sort of pattern
但这可能是一种肾上腺素和皮质醇驱动的能量，让你只是，你知道，全力以赴。然后作为回应，因为你的身体最终会说不，你就会进入一点低谷，在那里你就会进入萧条，这就是我们，你知道，通过这种反复的循环，甚至可以发现像慢性疼痛这样的东西，你知道，你的身体已经完全耗尽了所有资源，所以你已经用完了你所有的皮质醇，这会让你很难有动力去采取行动，而拖延可能是跟随那种模式的事情。
of overworking burnout procrastination and then you add a bit of self-criticism into that like what's wrong with me why am I so lazy lazy is a very very common word I hear what's wrong with me I'm not able to adult like other adults and that self-criticism then leads you into maybe just kicking yourself up the bum and thinking i'm gonna do it now but it's all motivated and fueled by criticism fear of failure um almost like a punitive um passionate unkindness is one of my clients um terms that she used once it's almost like that you everything you do is then fueled by fear of not being good enough or fear of failing and then that's very different to being fueled by a sense of joy vitality meaning like this feels really purposeful to me and I feel uplifted and
过度工作、倦怠、拖延，然后你再加一点自我批评，比如“我怎么了？为什么我这么懒？”“懒”是我听到的一个非常非常常见的词。“我怎么了？我不能像其他成年人一样成年。”而那种自我批评然后引导你也许只是踢自己的屁股，想“我现在就要做”，但这一切都是由批评、对失败的恐惧所驱动的，几乎就像一种惩罚性的、不友善的激情，这是我的一位客户曾经使用的一个词。这几乎就像你所做的一切都是由不够好的恐惧或失败的恐惧所驱动的，而这与由快乐、活力、意义感所驱动是非常不同的，比如“这对我来说真的很有意义，当我做这些事情时，我感到振奋和
light-hearted when I do these things if you felt that way I wouldn't say that your perfectionism is causing any problems for you so we kind of think about the difference between functional or dysfunctional perfectionism or it's working out for you so striving for excellence where you might not feel a sense of pride when you hit your ambitious goal you might feel a sense of joy at the things you've achieved that's very different you kind of think I'm highly skilled or I'm confident about what I do and I take great pleasure from it that's very different to striving for perfection which is associated with actually less likely to meet your goals or you meet them last minute and you meet them at the cost of your well-being so that's a really helpful distinction for anyone listening
轻松”。如果你有这种感觉，我就不会说你的完美主义给你造成了任何问题。所以我们思考功能性或功能障碍性完美主义之间的区别，或者它是否对你有效。所以追求卓越，当你达到雄心勃勃的目标时，你可能不会感到自豪，你可能会对你取得的成就感到快乐，这非常不同。你可能会想“我技术精湛”或“我对我的工作充满信心，我从中获得了极大的乐趣”，这与追求完美非常不同，追求完美实际上与不太可能达到你的目标有关，或者你最后一刻才达到，而且是以牺牲你的幸福为代价。所以这对任何听众来说都是一个非常有帮助的区别，
who has been thinking the perfectionism sure is a great thing because life would be perfect if I perfected everything and the reality is that it doesn't tend to be and I see that in a few different ways partly because we don't then take action to start you have so much second guessing and doubt um overthinking it trying to perfect everything so then don't start so someone listening might be like well I need to send three applications out and i just haven't sent any because they're not good enough right so if you don't take action you're not going to get any result you miss a hundred percent of the shots that you don't take um to quote wayne gretzky um yes i quoted a an ice hockey player on a psychology podcast
那些一直认为完美主义肯定是一件好事的人，因为如果我完善了一切，生活就会变得完美，但现实往往并非如此。我从几个不同的方面看到了这一点，部分原因是我们在开始时没有采取行动，你有太多的二次猜测和怀疑，你知道，过度思考，试图完善一切，所以就不开始。所以有人听了可能会想“好吧，我需要发出三份申请，但我一份都没发，因为它们不够好”，对吧？所以如果你不采取行动，你就不会得到任何结果。你错过了你没有射出的 100% 的球，引用 Wayne Gretzky 的话。是的，我在心理学播客上引用了一位冰球运动员的话。
so if you don't get started don't take action you won't get to a result so that's one thing i see the inertia and procrastination don't start or do start but it's not good enough and i'm not brilliant at it straight away so then people give up and they don't have that tenacity because it's not instantly rewarding and it's like imperfections want to be really brilliant at what they do immediately um or they get impatient or lastly they do finish it they get to that stretchy goal but they take no joy from it and can't savor their success they just look literally for the next mountain to climb even though they've just finished and they're exhausted so it doesn't sound that perfect does it um it really doesn't no and actually even when we get on to what feels like the Holy Grail and the clinical psychology doctorate, sometimes depending on which course you pick, sometimes that can fuel perfectionism as well.
所以如果你不开始，不采取行动，你就不会得到结果，所以这是我看到的一件事。惯性和拖延，不开始，或者开始了，但不够好，我不能马上变得出色，所以人们就放弃了，他们没有那种韧性，因为它不是即时奖励的。完美主义者想要立即在他们所做的事情上变得非常出色，或者他们变得不耐烦，或者最后，他们完成了，他们达到了那个伸展目标，但他们从中没有获得任何快乐，无法品味他们的成功。他们只是在寻找下一座要攀登的山，即使他们刚刚完成，而且他们精疲力竭。所以这听起来并不那么完美，不是吗？它真的不完美。不，实际上，即使当我们达到感觉像是圣杯的东西，即临床心理学博士学位时，有时根据你选择的课程，有时这也会助长完美主义。
So happily, I ended up on a course that doesn't give you grades for your assignments. So it was pass or fail with the pass rate being 40 percent. And so for my assignments, if I pass or fail with the pass rate being 40 percent and so um for my assignments if I passed I was happy and there was no like what did you get you know what did I get where am I did I come bottom because everybody was just pass or fail and actually I found that really really useful in just aiming to to do enough you know so I wanted to do you know I wanted to do well it wasn't like I was purposely thinking right I'm aiming for 40 percent um but you never got your percentages I just was aiming to cover the areas I thought would be reasonable as the best of I could best ability that I had but of course when we are training we're managing a caseload we're managing you know peer relations on the cohort we're
所以幸运的是，我最终参加了一门不给你的作业打分的课程。所以它是通过或不通过，通过率为 40%。所以对于我的作业，如果我通过或不通过，通过率为 40%，所以，嗯，对于我的作业，如果我通过了，我就很高兴，没有像“你得了多少分？”你知道，“我得了多少分？我在哪里？我是不是垫底了？”因为每个人都只是通过或不通过。实际上，我发现这在仅仅以做到足够好为目标方面非常非常有帮助。你知道，我想做，你知道，我想做得好，并不是说我故意在想“好吧，我的目标是 40%”，但你永远不会得到你的百分比。我只是想覆盖我认为合理的领域，尽我所能。但当然，当我们培训时，我们正在管理一个病例量，我们正在管理，你知道，同届学生中的同伴关系，我们正在
managing our real life which might be I moved for training so I had my real life where I was living my real life with my home friends where I grew up at one stage I was dating at one stage I was dating seriously you know different people different strokes different folks plus the academic work plus the relationship with my clinical my academic supervisor at uni and then the staff that were teaching us and relationships with the people facilitating that it's a lot a lot and so for me just that one thing I think helped me keep everything all those plates spinning you know and balls in the air because I didn't have to you know try not to be last you know in my academic work and not be not being graded on a curve like that either that's it's not so
管理我们的现实生活，这可能是，我为了培训搬家了，所以我有了我的现实生活，我在那里过着我的现实生活，和我在那里长大的朋友们在一起。有一段时间我在约会，有一段时间我在认真约会，你知道，不同的人，不同的方式，加上学术工作，加上我在大学的临床、学术导师的关系，然后是教我们的员工，以及促进这一点的人们的关系，这很多，很多。所以对我来说，仅仅那一件事，我想帮助我保持一切，所有那些旋转的盘子，你知道，球在空中，因为我不必，你知道，试图不成为最后一名，你知道，在我的学术工作中，也不像那样被曲线评分。那不是那么
performative but it's more about building the identity and the skill set of a scientist practitioner of a clinical psychologist we had the same in my training it was only pass or fail given and I then struggled when I moved to the UK and was doing the academic training that's part of IAPT so obviously it was a year PGGIP with Royal Holloway and then suddenly there was like distinctions and all sorts of things i've never had this before it was a real learning curve for me and knowing that i people in the uk are learning how to do application processes and interviews so much earlier than we do you're evaluated for much earlier you've come to understand this from like 11 year pluses and
表演性的，但更多的是关于建立科学家从业者、临床心理学家的身份和技能组合。我在我的培训中也有同样的情况，只给通过或不通过。然后当我搬到英国并进行作为 IAPT 一部分的学术培训时，我挣扎了。所以显然那是与 Royal Holloway 的一年 PGDEP，然后突然之间有像优等成绩和各种各样的东西，我以前从未有过这个，这对我来说是一个真正的学习曲线。而且知道我，英国的人们学习如何进行申请过程和面试比我们早得多。你被评估得早得多，你从 11 岁以上和
gcses and all sorts so i didn't have that experience so I didn't know how to academically write in a way to tick the boxes to get the higher marks and that was really really hard and it's something that sort of I'm going to say it out loud because that's what happens with shame it makes us want to hide so I'm going to say it that I only got only got a pass in my PGDEP there and has anyone ever asked to see it since no am i a good psychologist yes i've taught psychology at both uel and ucl i've run my own private practice obviously i've been working as a senior psychologist in in the nhs for seven years i ran a um a staff well-being clinic where i headed up the cT service at Guyson St Thomas hospital
GCSE 以及各种各样的事情中就开始理解这一点，所以我没有那种经验。所以我不知道如何以一种打勾的方式进行学术写作以获得更高的分数，这真的非常非常困难。这是某种，我要大声说出来，因为这就是羞耻感发生的事情，它让我们想要隐藏。所以我说出来，我在那里的 PGDEP 中只得了及格。从那以后有人要求看它吗？没有。我是一名优秀的心理学家吗？是的，我在 UEL 和 UCL 都教过心理学，我经营着自己的私人诊所，显然我在 NHS 担任高级心理学家七年了，我经营着一个员工健康诊所，我在 Guyson St Thomas 医院负责 CBT 服务。
you know headhunted to do exactly that did anyone go oh but you only had a pass yeah no I'm sorry no if you'd only put more effort into those um those scientific uh articles that you're reviewing so you could have had a distinction that we would have picked you it doesn't work like that so I really want to take some of that external pressure away from you, that the evaluation that is happening through academia stops to have that same relevance when you're in academia. But then being aware of it does. But then sometimes it doesn't. Because if people got a 2-2 undergrad or 2-2 at at masters sometimes they are penalized for that or they're asked to do additional things or they're told it just doesn't count you know it's not good enough
你知道吗，有人被猎头挖去做的正是这些事。有没有人会说，但你只有一个及格成绩啊？是的，我很抱歉，不，如果你在那些你正在审阅的科学文章上多花点心思，你本可以拿到优等成绩，那样我们就会选你了。事情不是那样运作的，所以我真的想帮你卸下一些外部压力，学术界进行的评估当你身处学术界时，其相关性就不再那么重要了。但意识到这一点很重要。不过有时它确实很重要。因为如果人们在本科或硕士阶段只拿到了二等二学位，有时他们会因此受到惩罚，或者被要求做额外的事情，或者被告知这根本不算数，你知道，这还不够好。
so certainly for assistant psych roles what i meant is my the sort of late later on because this was obviously the pg dip i did on top of my you know msc the equivalent of your declined psych so yeah absolutely when you when you're looking to go into that bottleneck of the application process of wanting to get onto the doctoral training absolutely that does count on that one i just meant what you do after that so that's why it's so helpful that like for instance your doctoral training did only had passed and failed because beyond that point when you come out and you are a budding psychologist there are so many other ways of evaluating your skill set through you know really good supervision and having you know uh reviews of of your work so yeah so yeah just to to reiterate that obviously it doesn't it's not like it doesn't matter what grades you
所以对于助理心理学家的职位，我指的是我后来经历的，因为这显然是我在硕士学位之外修读的心理学研究生文凭，相当于你们的心理学学位，所以是的，绝对的，当你想要进入那个申请博士培训的瓶颈期时，那确实很重要。我只是指在那之后你所做的事情，所以这就是为什么像你的博士培训只看及格与否非常有帮助，因为在那之后，当你毕业成为一名初出茅庐的心理学家时，还有很多其他方式来评估你的技能，比如通过非常好的督导和对你工作的评估，所以是的，重申一下，这并不是说你的成绩不重要。
get as you go through your undergrad and assistant psych posts and things I just meant more I wish for people to put less pressure on themselves to nail every single thing perfectly because when you then start to work clinically in the real world at that point it doesn't matter it really doesn't um and i like your um thinking about other ways we can learn about not being perfectionistic as well and what i'm referring to is michaela is the author of a wonderful book which i've got here if you're on youtube with a lovely gold swirly pattern there which i really like the lasting connection by michaela thomas and that is a compassionate therapy guide for thinking about relationships isn't it Michaela talk us through briefly your book baby because I know we're not talking about relationships here but I think this is a lovely book and it's yeah it would be remiss
在你读本科和担任助理心理学家期间，我只是希望人们少给自己施加压力，不要试图把每一件事都做得完美无缺，因为当你开始在现实世界中进行临床工作时，那一点都不重要，真的不重要。我喜欢你关于学习如何不追求完美的想法，我指的是Michaela，她是一本精彩书籍的作者，如果你们在YouTube上观看的话，我手里正拿着这本书，封面上有着漂亮的金色漩涡图案，我非常喜欢，书名是《持久的联系》（The Lasting Connection），作者是Michaela Thomas，这是一本关于思考人际关系的慈悲疗法指南，不是吗？Michaela，简单介绍一下你的书吧，因为我知道我们今天不是在谈论人际关系，但我认为这是一本很棒的书，如果我不让你在我的播客上提到它，那就太失职了。
of me not to allow yourself to not to allow you to to mention that um when you're on my podcast that's very kind and compassionate of you, Marianne, knowing how hard it is to do book promotion. So The Lasting Connection, I still wrote with people who are high-striving and perfectionistic in mind. There's a whole chapter on connection, not perfection, because when we're really hard on ourselves and we don't give ourselves enough grace or self-compassion
那是你非常善良和富有同情心，Marianne，我知道做书籍推广有多难。所以《持久的联系》这本书，我依然是为那些高追求和追求完美的人而写的。书中有一整章关于“联系，而非完美”，因为当我们对自己非常苛刻，没有给自己足够的宽容或自我慈悲时，
for mistakes we make, etc., it will have an impact on our relationships. So the book is based on the three different methods or models I use in my couples work, which is, as you mentioned, compassion-focused therapy, but also acceptance and commitment therapy or ACT, as well as behavioral couples therapy, which is sort of like a cbt version for for couples so i blended these three together and i couldn't find anyone who'd written a book like that on that subject so i decided maybe i should so that's where the book baby was uh where it was coming from and i i feel like it's sort of there's a lot of things out there around communication training and how to
对于我们犯的错误等等，这会影响到我们的人际关系。所以这本书基于我在夫妻治疗中使用的三种不同的方法或模型，正如你提到的，慈悲聚焦疗法，还有接纳承诺疗法（ACT），以及行为夫妻治疗，这有点像是夫妻版的CBT，所以我把这三种方法融合在一起，我找不到有人写过关于这个主题的书，所以我决定也许我应该写一本，这就是这本书的由来。我觉得市面上有很多关于沟通训练以及如何
improve your decision making obviously the work of people like John Gottman and Julia Gottman so there's a lot of that out there already that I've cited in the book but I wanted to add to it is also how we can soften and soothe very sort of high triggering situations that we ultimately have when we live so close to someone in proximity with someone every day is that idea of how do I bring down that threat how do I de-escalate and soothe that through compassion so you have everything from mindfulness practices to breath work to uh compassionate letter writing in the book to you know finding a way to talk to your inner critical voice in a different way so developing your compassionate self and and also how you are compassionate towards others so I saw a lot about how we are
改善决策的内容，显然像John Gottman和Julia Gottman等人的工作，书中已经引用了很多，但我想要补充的是，当我们每天与某人近距离生活在一起时，如何软化和安抚那些极易触发矛盾的情况。这就是如何降低威胁感，如何通过慈悲来化解和安抚冲突。所以书中涵盖了从正念练习、呼吸训练到慈悲书写练习，以及如何以不同的方式与你内心的批判声音对话，从而培养你的慈悲自我，以及如何对他人的慈悲。所以我看到了很多关于我们如何
with the other partner how you are towards them but I didn't see enough about how you are towards yourself so that's why I wrote the book on that subject on how to develop compassion for yourself and your partner well done and it's a really great read and actually i recommend it to clients who don't have relationships as well because it really i think helps people think about what a good relationship will look like and how it actually is supposed to enrich your life not deplete it and so you can still be your own person it's important that you are um and well done, because it's a really lovely book. And I know that Dr. Julie Smith and Deliciously Ella are big fans
对待另一半，以及你如何对待他们，但我没有看到足够多关于你如何对待自己的内容，所以我写了这本书，关于如何培养对自己和伴侣的慈悲。做得好，这是一本非常棒的书。事实上，我也向没有伴侣的客户推荐它，因为它我认为能帮助人们思考一段好的关系是什么样子的，以及它实际上应该如何丰富你的生活，而不是消耗它，所以你仍然可以做你自己，这很重要。做得好，因为这是一本非常可爱的书。我知道Julie Smith博士和Deliciously Ella也是它的忠实粉丝。
of it as well. So well done to you. And another one of your babies is another thing that I like to listen to. And it is your Pause Purpose Play podcast. could you tell us a little bit about that as well yeah of course and you know incidentally someone really amazing has done an episode on grief on it uh dr marianne trent if you want to check out that episode then search for marianne trent and grief and pause purpose play and you can listen to your fantastic host as well um it's a podcast that is it's a psychology podcast, and it's aimed at high striving women who put a lot of pressure on themselves to be perfect, who might have really stretchy, ambitious goals, but as a result, they then find themselves being overstretched or
他们也非常喜欢。所以为你感到骄傲。你的另一个“孩子”是另一个我喜欢听的东西，那就是你的《暂停、目标、游戏》（Pause Purpose Play）播客。你能也给我们介绍一下那个吗？当然可以，顺便说一下，一位非常了不起的人在上面做了一期关于悲伤的节目，那就是Marianne Trent博士。如果你想收听那一集，搜索“Marianne Trent and grief and pause purpose play”，你也可以收听你这位出色的主持人。这是一个心理学播客，旨在帮助那些对自己要求极高、追求完美、可能有着非常宏大目标，但结果却发现自己过度劳累或
drowning in their ambition, maybe then either overworking, feeling, you know, burnt out, or don't take action and hold themselves back with self-doubt fear and procrastination so basically the things we've talked about today that's the what I cover on the podcast and it's a mix of guest interviews where I talk about sort of everything related to perfectionism and then how we improve our well-being as recovering perfectionists and solo episodes with me where I sort of do 10-15 minutes sort of short nuggets of learning around this concept of perfectionism so go check it out if you think you are a bit of a perfectionist and you're not quite sure it's just good in your life and you might want to consider the costs of your
被野心淹没的女性，也许因此过度工作、感到精疲力竭，或者因为自我怀疑、恐惧和拖延而不敢采取行动。所以基本上我们今天谈论的内容就是我在播客中涵盖的主题。它混合了嘉宾访谈，我谈论与完美主义相关的一切，以及作为康复中的完美主义者我们如何改善幸福感，还有我的个人单口节目，我会在10-15分钟内分享关于完美主义概念的简短学习心得。所以如果你认为自己有点完美主义，但不确定它在生活中是否健康，并且想考虑一下完美主义的代价，
perfectionism as well you can go and check it out brilliant thank you so much so before we finish before we share your contact details and everything could you offer us your top tip for our audience for how to reduce the chance of burnout in this career of ours? Wow. Meaty. I think being really aware of what is the external pressure that you're under and what is the internal pressure that you bring with you. So the external pressure, to be aware of that, if it's no longer serving you, and it might be that even as psychologists, we can enter toxic environments at work,
你也可以去听听看。太棒了，非常感谢。那么在我们结束之前，在我们分享你的联系方式之前，你能为我们的听众提供一个关于如何减少我们这个职业中职业倦怠可能性的秘诀吗？哇，这可是个重头戏。我认为要非常清楚你所承受的外部压力是什么，以及你带来的内部压力是什么。所以对于外部压力，要意识到如果它不再为你服务，即使作为心理学家，我们也可能进入有毒的工作环境，
be it in the private or the public sector. If you're aware there's an external pressure that is too heavy on you, and you're about to experience burnout, then also think about how much internal pressure do you take with you by having unrealistic high standards or excessive demands on yourself to be a certain way so being aware where that external and internal pressure meet and if they've come together as a perfect storm that is an opportunity for you to practice self-compassion
无论是在私营部门还是公共部门。如果你意识到有一种外部压力对你来说太沉重，并且你即将经历职业倦怠，那么也要思考一下，你通过设定不切实际的高标准或对自己提出过分要求来给自己带来了多少内部压力。所以要意识到外部压力和内部压力在哪里交汇，如果它们汇聚成了一场完美的风暴，那正是你练习自我慈悲的机会。
that no wonder that I'm really stressed out here no wonder I'm at the point of burnout because I'm in a high demands environment with unrelenting high standards on me and how I should perform as a psychologist or trainee and then I have my internal world saying it's never good enough and I beat myself up for making mistakes and you know what in you in a high external pressure environment you're also more likely to make mistakes because you're overworked so that would probably be my top tip to help you make wise decisions about when you stay and when you leave and when you actually decide that this is not coming from the environment it's coming from me maybe reaching out to someone
难怪我在这里感到压力很大，难怪我到了职业倦怠的边缘，因为我身处一个高要求的环境中，对我作为心理学家或实习生的表现有着无情的严苛标准，然后我的内心世界又在说“这还不够好”，我因为犯错而责备自己。你知道吗，在高外部压力的环境下，你因为过度劳累也更容易犯错。所以这可能是我给你的最佳建议，帮助你做出明智的决定，关于何时留下，何时离开，以及当你真正决定这并非来自环境，而是来自我自身时，也许可以向某人求助，
like myself or you know speaking to someone in counseling therapy coaching whatever it might be to get you some help to soften those coulds and you know the musts and the shoulds that you have on yourself and it might be that you're able to thrive in a even in a high demands environment if you shave away some of the internal pressure thank you so much that's really really useful stuff to consider and now if people do want to get themselves on your mailing list and be able to respond to your mailing list emails like I do, what's the best way to do that, Michaela? Well, I obviously have a bunch of nice freebies. So if you want to just sign up to the newsletter,
比如像我这样的人，或者咨询心理治疗师、教练等，无论是什么，去寻求帮助来软化那些你强加给自己的“本可以”、“必须”和“应该”。也许即使在高要求的环境中，如果你削减掉一些内部压力，你也能茁壮成长。非常感谢，这些建议非常非常有用。现在，如果人们想加入你的邮件列表，并像我一样回复你的邮件，最好的方式是什么，Michaela？嗯，我显然有很多不错的免费资源。所以如果你想注册通讯，
you can go to thethomasconnection.co.uk forward slash newsletter. But if you actually want something for your time, you can go to thethomasconnection.co. uk forward slash newsletter but if you actually want something for your time you can go to the thomas connection dot co dot uk forward slash calm and download my calm the overwhelm freebie where you can look through a checklist of physical and psychological signs of overwhelm some very quick simple tips for what you can do to implement some self-care and also the little objections that the stuff that gets in the way of you actually doing those things. Because as psychologists, we have lots of tools and tricks and tips for how to look after ourselves. And the biggest thing I see is that people don't tend to do it. So that implementation is very hard.
你可以访问thethomasconnection.co.uk/newsletter。但如果你真的想为你的时间换取一些东西，你可以访问thethomasconnection.co.uk/calm，下载我的“平息压倒感”（Calm the Overwhelm）免费资源，在那里你可以查看一份关于压倒感的生理和心理迹象的清单，获取一些非常快速简单的自我关怀建议，以及那些阻碍你真正实施这些建议的小借口。因为作为心理学家，我们有很多照顾自己的工具、技巧和建议。但我看到最大的问题是人们往往不去执行。所以执行起来非常困难。
So get on my mailing list if you want to have some ongoing tips on how you can work with this. And I'd love for you to say reply like Marianne does and that will make my day brilliant and if you have you got a favorite hangout on socials where's the best place for people to like your stuff and engage with your stuff because that's always important isn't it it is and yeah so obviously I put a lot more out on socials than I than I do in the newsletters as well the newsletter the the one that I have on Fridays which is may I swear that it's called Friday and that newsletter is all about letting go of these sort of rigid rules that we have for ourselves that is exclusive to to the mailing list but otherwise I hang out on Instagram and the underscore Thomas underscore
所以如果你想获得关于如何处理这些问题的持续建议，请加入我的邮件列表。我很乐意看到你像Marianne那样回复我，那会让我的一天变得很美好。太棒了。你在社交媒体上有最喜欢的互动平台吗？人们在哪里最容易喜欢你的内容并与你互动？因为这总是很重要的，不是吗？是的，显然我在社交媒体上发布的内容比在通讯中发布的多。周五的那封通讯，我可以发誓它叫“周五”，那封通讯是关于放下我们为自己设定的那些僵化规则，这是邮件列表独有的。除此之外，我在Instagram上，账号是_Thomas_connection，
connection or Michaela Thomas on LinkedIn on linkedin so instagram and linkedin perfect and i regularly interact with you both those places and more thank you so much for sharing your wisdom with us and your kindness i know that people will find what you've said really really useful so thank you so much thank you for having me and i don't think it was perfect but it was good enough and i'm happy with that it certainly was thank you michaela what a pleasure it was perfect, but it was good enough. And I'm happy with that. It certainly was. Thank you, Michaela. What a pleasure it was to spend time on camera with one of my colleagues, but also someone who's become a dear, close friend over the last couple of years. Hope you found it so useful listening to Michaela and I.
或者在LinkedIn上搜索Michaela Thomas。所以Instagram和LinkedIn是完美的。我经常在这两个地方以及更多地方与你互动。非常感谢你与我们分享你的智慧和善意，我知道人们会发现你所说的一切非常非常有用，所以非常感谢。谢谢你邀请我，我不认为这很完美，但已经足够好了，对此我很满意。确实如此，谢谢你，Michaela。能和我的同事，同时也是过去几年里成为亲密好友的人在镜头前共度时光，真是太荣幸了。希望你觉得听我和Michaela的对话很有用。
I'd love any feedback. Come and join us over on the Aspiring Psychologist Community Free Facebook group. Let me know what you think. I love creating content that you want to listen to, read, watch, depending on whether you're reading this on the blog, whether you're watching this on YouTube. Like, subscribe subscribe comment if you are um and if you're like oh i didn't know that was on youtube we are it's dr marianne trent over on youtube so come and follow and subscribe there um and if you're listening to this on podcast our most popular podcast platform is spotify followed then, I think, by Apple.
我很乐意收到任何反馈。来加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费Facebook群组吧。让我知道你的想法。我喜欢创作你们想听、想读、想看的内容，取决于你是在博客上阅读，还是在YouTube上观看。点赞、订阅、评论，如果你是……如果你想“哦，我不知道这在YouTube上也有”，我们确实在YouTube上，账号是Dr Marianne Trent，所以去关注并订阅吧。如果你是在播客上听这个节目，我们最受欢迎的播客平台是Spotify，其次我想是Apple。
If you're listening on Apple, take a moment to rate and review the podcast series as that helps us get shown higher up the listings and shows that we are creating useful content that our audience find useful. Regardless of whether you're watching, listening or reading, if you've got stuff that you'd like me to discuss or people you'd like me to chat with, then let me know. Get in contact with me via my socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, all places, or via my specific podcast page on the website, which is www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And that's where you can access all episodes of the podcast via my website if you didn't want to access it via Spotify or any of the other means. And you can also fill in a form. You can also, whilst you're there, record me a very quick audio testimonial, either about the podcast or one of the books to use within the show.
如果你是在Apple上收听，请花点时间给播客系列评分和评论，因为这有助于我们在列表中获得更高的排名，并表明我们正在创作听众认为有用的内容。无论你是观看、收听还是阅读，如果你有想让我讨论的话题，或者想让我采访的人，请告诉我。通过我的社交媒体与我联系。我是Dr. Marianne Trent，所有平台同名，或者通过我网站上的特定播客页面，网址是www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。如果你不想通过Spotify或其他方式访问，可以在我的网站上访问播客的所有剧集。你也可以填写表格。你还可以在那里录制一段非常简短的音频感言，关于播客或其中一本书，以便在节目中使用。
So yeah, if you've got a couple of minutes, that would be so welcomed. And if you've got a couple of spare pounds in your pocket and you value the content, please do consider donating to help me with the podcast running costs, as that is something that I fund entirely myself. To find out information about that, check out the link in the show notes or go to my link tree, which you can access from any of my socials. Thank you so much for being part of my world. And I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be available for you on Monday at 6am. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I'll catch up with you very soon. Take care. to learn from so many things that you can try
所以，如果你有几分钟时间，那将非常受欢迎。如果你口袋里有几块钱，并且认为这些内容有价值，请考虑捐款以帮助我支付播客的运营成本，因为这是我完全自费的项目。要了解相关信息，请查看节目说明中的链接，或访问我的Linktree，你可以从我的任何社交媒体上访问它。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着在下一期《有抱负的心理学家》播客中与你相见，该节目将于周一早上6点发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快就会再见。保重。有很多东西可以尝试去学习。
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified
有抱负的心理学家集体，有抱负的心理学家集体。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Durant My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，主持人是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为一名心理学家没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切
will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。